the Joe Rogan experience it's to me a
hits home because I needed to know when
I needed to retire to when I stopped
fighting I knew it was like I'm not
doing this the way I used to do this you
know I used to be completely obsessed
but I saw a bunch of people get knocked
out I knocked a bunch of people out I
knew that that easily could have is near
like to knock somebody else
it's weird it's a bittersweet feeling
like you don't feel good you know it
feels if you were in a true combat
position it would feel good well
fighting for your life you mean yeah
competition I mean it was all people my
age you know I was 19 20 years old and
I'm standing over this unconscious
version of me you know that I just
kicked in the head and that's how the
person yeah the amount of force you can
generate with a kick it's just so
terrifying it's so terrifying you know
the thing that that's gonna bounce off
your head and the lights go out and then
you could incur legitimate permanent
brain damage from something like that I
was in the initial kick or in the hit
with a drop all the canvas both this the
kick someone kicks you in the head
someone who really knows how to kick
they bounce a [ __ ] shin off your
temple you might not ever be the same
again
that's real been knocked out I've never
been knocked out I've been stopped
which means I got TKO I got dropped with
a punch and then the guy followed up
with a bunch of punches and the referee
stopped the fight that was the last
fight I ever had there's a lot of slow
down yeah I got I was in a kickboxing
fight okay actually there's three fights
in a day I won the first two won the
first one by knockout I beat the [ __ ]
out of the second guy and I was pretty
sick actually going into the fight going
into the the turn I would get sick
sometimes because I'll be nervous and
[ __ ] I wasn't my nutrition was terrible
and then the third fight I got hit with
a left hook I got I won the first round
and in the second round I got hit with a
left hook and my legs just went bleep
they just stopped working
I remember going what the [ __ ] [ __ ] I
could never been dropped like that
before where my legs just he was a
perfect left hook he just caught me
crunk riding a chance so what if he
catches you on the chin what is the what
happening that it's it it's like it
connects range what's your brain right
and your brain like it also does
something that's like nerves behind your
jaw and when you get hit hard
it just it's like an electrical charge
goes into your body and everything just
shuts off it's weird like it was totally
conscious but my legs just stopped
working and then fell all that happening
while that's happening more punches are
coming no because it was kickboxing
wasn't MMA and MMA the guy would jump on
you and they'd stop it right there or
you would maybe grab a hold of them and
maybe you would survive maybe you
wouldn't you know there's arguments that
it's safer in MMA because they stop it
quicker
there's also arguments in when it goes
to the ground you could actually survive
better and you could hold on and maybe
that would allow you to take more damage
and maybe that's not as safe I'm in the
former camp I think it's safer okay
because I think when fights get stopped
quicker it's safer but so when you got
adjusted and electricity went there did
you go down yeah I went down my legs my
legs just stopped working like this like
I'm standing up he hit me and didn't I
just go plank yeah he went down yes
under your ass yeah I went down and I
got up before the count of ten referee
dust your gloves off and the kids
swarmed at me again hit me with a bunch
more punches and I covered up in the
referee stopped the fight so that was a
TKO which is technical knockout but I
had already known that I was kind of I
was already doing stand-up comedy at
that time as well and I didn't know then
I was half in half out and then I had a
wait when is this 1989 so this is even
before this before news radio
oh yeah way before yeah this was or be
funny no well I knew I knew somewhere
around the time I was 19 that this was
not there was no future in this and I
was trying to make the Olympic team
which was the Nationals were in Miami in
1988 and wait were you from Boston
that's where I was Adam so I was a
Massachusetts state champion and then I
would go to these national tournaments
and compete against like the show the
Illinois champion
I'm sure champion and
[Applause]